conspiracy theorists say the truth is
out there but now it's NASA scientists
who are seeking it out they spent nearly
a year trying to understand UFOs or uaps
as the experts call them they've looked
at hundreds of cases some to fight
explanation
this video was shot at an unnamed
location in the Middle East it shows a
round object flying at high speed
but while the Pal doesn't know what it
is they say there's no evidence
phenomena like this has anything to do
with aliens
the current existing data and eyewitness
reports alone are insufficient to
provide conclusive evidence about the
nature and origin of of every UAP event
they're often uninformative due to lack
of quality control and data curation
many sightings could be explained
these three lights in the sky appear to
be moving together in an unusual way
they turned out to be aircraft headed
for a major airport the strange movement
came from a shaking video recorder only
a very small percentage of UAP reports
display signatures that could reasonably
be described as anomalous
the majority of unidentified objects
reported to arrow and in our Holdings
demonstrate mundane characteristics of
readily explainable sources
for decades the US government had been
dismissive of UFO reports but in recent
years there's been a more open approach
the NASA pal is working in tandem with
the Pentagon and while some sightings
can be explained many questions remain
Vincent Monaghan Al Jazeera